I will be presenting novel therapies in marginal zone lymphoma, University of Miami experience.
We're currently running three IAT studies, and I will present you all this.
As you know, treatment of extranodal marginal zone lymphoma is not well established.
There was only one randomized trial, ISLG-19, that compared rituximab to rituximab versus
chlorambucil and demonstrated the combination induces better event-free survival, but there
was no difference in overall survival.
So consequently, we don't have uniform approaches for treatment of newly diagnosed and relapsed
marginal zone lymphoma patients.
These slides demonstrate some of the previous studies for the treatment of upfront marginal
zone lymphoma, including extranodal marginal zone lymphoma.
You can see heterogeneity.
Overall responses are ranging wide range, as well as complete responses.
But currently, the most common regimen that is used is arbendamastin for treatment of
marginal zone lymphoma, extranodal and nodal, and for splenic, it's only rituximab alone.
So this is the first study, and the data is not published, so it's confidential, so don't
take pictures.
So this is a phase two trial of mozentuzumab in patients with newly diagnosed extranodal
marginal zone lymphoma.
Patients underwent staging with PET-CT, MRI-OCT based on the site of involvement, and they
received subcutaneous mozentuzumab, cross-cycle step-up dosing, and then standard dose of
mozentuximab for eight cycles with restaging after a fourth cycle.
The goal of this study is to enroll 35 patients, and the primary endpoint is complete response
risk based on our previous studies published in JCO.
And the studies by Kohn-Bambamir, they demonstrated that it represents a very promising surrogate
marker for progression-free survival and overall survival.
The patient populations, the median age was 65 patients, and we present planned interim
analysis that was performed on February 16, 2026, and study started at the end of 2024.
19 patients were enrolled.
We have a mix.
We have an increase in the number of patients with multiple stages of disease.
that in patients that we had
till this point, complete response was achieved in 87.5%
for 14 patients, and partial response was achieved in 12.2 patients.
There was no progressions, and there was no loss.
This is a swimmer plot,
and you can see that many of the responses were achieved already after four cycles.
The single patient that's shown in blue, this is
a patient with partial response. The patient initially presented with lung
and stomach involvement. After two cycles,
endoscopy was performed, and the patient was already in complete remission at the site
of the stomach, and this was completely
confirmed also after eight cycles, but she had persistent lung mass.
When we have biopsies of lung mass and remove the lung mass, it was amyloid
without evidence of margins or lymphoma, but we can't count it
as a partial response.
The responses were durable, as I mentioned. Side effects.
All the patients had some type of adverse events,
a total of 117. Grade 3 for adverse events were observed
in three patients. One patient with tumor flare, grade 3,
grade 3, grade 4, sorry. This patient had, at initial presentation, a very
large mass encasing optic nerve in the eye, and during
the tumor treatment, he developed or progression of
disease initially on the first cycle, or
tumor flare that led eventually to loss of vision. However,
here this is stage 4 disease, and eventually he achieved complete response
and doing well. One patient had neutropenia, grade 4, and one patient
has skin rash, grade 3. CRS was common and was observed
26 events of CRS. On the right, you can see
the most common side effects, and this was a CRS.
With regard to CRS, it was observed in 16 out of 19 patients.
Most common side effects, and this was a CRS. With regard to CRS, it was observed in 16 out of 19 patients.
Mostly during the first cycle, there was one event of grade 2, all the rest were grade 1. There was two patients that had also CRS at cycle 2. All the patients went through CRS without hospitalization. All the patients had complete resolution of the CRS, and they were treated with steroids.
Relapse setting. So, this is a slide summarizing relapse setting.
early life setting of the patient treatment. We will focus on the magnificent study that was
the study that was available when we designed this study, and we aimed to beat the 26%
complete response rate. This is a study design, six cycles of longostuximab given in a standard
dose. Once again, patient is staged with PET-CT, MRIs, and CAT scans. And by the way, in both
studies, all the patients were PET-AVID. The aim of enrollment was 50 patients. The analysis here
was performed in February 2025. Both of them planned analysis. Total 27 patients were enrolled.
Once again, good representation with quite significant number of Hispanic. The subdivision
between external nodal margins on the FOMADES clinic is observed in SEER database, and
the majority of the patient had advanced stage disease. Progression of disease within 24 months
was observed previously in 48. Percent of the patient, median number of previous cycles,
two cycles. Relapse patient, 63%. Refractory patient, 37. Patient received different therapies,
including chemotherapy by specific inhibitors and CAR-Ts. As of February 10, 26 patients were
evaluated. The overall response was 85%, with CR rate of 69%, very significant CR rate. Longer led
to CR in 8 of 13 patients with POD 24. And single patient post-CAR-T achieved complete response rate,
and he continues to be in complete response till now. On the right, you see the swimmer plot,
and once again, many of the responses are observed after two cycles. CR is currently maintained. In
17 of the 18 patients at the time of this analysis, the rate of ongoing CR at 18 months
was 83%, and the longest duration of CR was 27 months. In one patient with dual external nodal
marginal zone lymphoma, she relapsed after 17.5 months after achieving CR. By reverse Kaplan-Meyer
methods, the median duration of CR was 13.7 months at this point of time, and the median duration of
CR PR was 13.2 months. At 12 months, the median duration of CR PR was 13.2 months. At 12 months,
the median duration of CR PR was 92%. PFS at 12 months was 91%, and all the patients are alive till
now. Safety. Generally, long-term was well-tolerated, and observed safety was consistent with known
profile. 27 patients experienced expected advanced events, most commonly grade 1 and 2. Grade 3 and
4 advanced events were observed in 16 and 2 patients, respectively. Three patients needed dose reduction.
One patient discontinued treatment after cycle 4 because of cholestatic hepatitis confirmed by biopsy.
Patient clinically recovered completely, and is in CR with discontinued CR. As you can see on the
right, the most common side effects as expected were a rash, increased abnormalities in liver
function test, and neutropenia, and some edema. In conclusion, LONCA demonstrates clinically
meaningful activity with a robust CR rate in patients with relapsed refractory marginal zone lymphoma,
in our ongoing study, and passed first and already second interim fertility analysis
measure for early stopping. We most probably will finish the study by the end of the year.
The treatment is well-tolerated, and the safety profile is consistent with known adverse events,
and no unexpected toxicity. Lignite depression demonstrated durable CR,
and we will report, hopefully attach, the CR rates, how they, if they are continuous,
or not. This study, by the way, was a multicenter study, and I would like to
acknowledge the other contributors. This is City of Hope, Vanderbilt, and Emory. Thank you.